翻訳: Naoko Hirami
校正: Hiroko Kawano
突然ですけども
みなさんは何色が好きでしょうか？
この世界はまさに色に溢れています
今日皆さんがここの会場に来るまでにも
沢山の色があったでしょうし
ここの会場にもいろんな色があります
皆さんが着ている服であったり
髪の色 肌の色
いろんな色があると思います
人間というのは
何百色の色を認識する力があります
ということで 目に見える色だけではなくて
目に見えない色というのも
私たちは認識しているのかもしれません
これは例えば アイデンティティの色だったり
その人が放つ色
それぞれの人が
私はなにかの色を放っていると思っています
今日は皆さんに 私がこういった
対話の場を企画する際に心がけている
色の見方 考え方 そして色の表現の仕方
こういったことをお話ししたいと思います
まずは今日は
皆さんに見て頂きたい1枚の絵があります
こちらなんですけども かわいいですね
実はこのイラストは
私がボランティアで運営しているある団体の
参加してくれている実在の子どもたちです
モデルになった子どもたちを絵にしてくれたのは
日系カナダ人アニメーターの
ジェフ・チバ・スターンさんという方です
非常に多彩な子どもたちが
描かれているんですけども
私は普段ミックスルーツジャパンという
団体をやってるんですけども
この中にいろんな意味が込められているんです
ミックスルーツというのは人種だけに限らず
いろいろな文化 いろいろな経験
文化経験 継承したもの
こういったさまざまなルーツが
ひとりひとりの中で混ざって
それがアイデンティティだと
思っている人たち
そういったすごく幅が広い
いろいろな多様な人たちの対話の場
お互いの対話の場を作っています
そして 互いが対話するだけではなくて
それを社会全体にどういう風に
対話につなげていくか？
少しイメージが分かりにくいと
思うんですけれども
例えば こういったアートであったりとか
音楽を使ったワークショップ
のちほど紹介します
いろいろな方がご覧になっていると
神戸でこれはやったんですけど
そして 非常にかわいい子供たちが参加してる
子ども会ですね
これは年に何回かある
見ての通りハロウィンで
ここはもちろん楽しむ お互いの
いろんな人たちがいる
もしくは 自分の周りに
こういう人がいなかったけども
同じような人いるじゃないとか
こんな違う人がいるんだ
子どもにとっての気づきでもあるし
親同士の情報交換の場にも
なったりするわけですね
上映会
色々なドキュメンタリーだったり
映画を上映するんですけども
この後にちゃんとお客さんの皆さんと
ディスカッションしたりしています
そして月１でここ神戸から
コミュニティーラジオをやってるんです
こちらも実は 阪神大震災の直後にできた
まさにいろいろな多様な人たちが
コミュニケーションを取れるように
マイノリティーの方からそして障害を持った方
色々な人が番組を持っています
地域のお年寄りも番組を持っています
ここは10言語で放送してるんですけども
そのうちのひとつを放送させて頂いています
そして もうかれこれ10年弱
9年活動してきたので
それぞれのこういった色を
今後未来に生かすために
やはりちゃんとしたデータであったり
研究も必要だということで
こういった研究会などもやっています
少しこの絵に戻るんですけども
この絵を見た時に 皆さんは
どういったストーリーを
思い浮かべるでしょうか
この絵が好きなのは
かわいいだけだからではないんですね
まさに塗り絵のように白黒
まだ白黒の絵なんです
みなさんだったらどんな色を
この絵に付けられるでしょうか？
その色の選び方 どういった色を付けるか？
これによっていろいろなストーリーが
変わってくるかもしれません
例えばこれが自分のお子さんだったら
こういう子に育ってほしい もしくは
あなたには
こういったルーツを受け継いでほしい
こういう色付けのしかたもあるかもしれません
受け継ぐ色も大事ですけども
やはり理想としては
この子どもたちがいずれ
自分たちで自分の色を見つけて
そして自分を色づけする
しかし社会ですので
お互いをやはり影響しあうのは防げません
さらには あまりにもいろいろな色があると
「これをどうしよう？」と 非常に
混乱してしまうこともあるかもしれません
初めて見る色 もしくは初めて見る
色のコンビネーション
社会の中ではこういった様々な人たちが
増えていく今の世の中で
「未来はどうなるんだ？」
色々な考え方があります
１つは例えば「メルティングポット」
すべての色をひとつの鍋に入れて
ぐつぐつ煮てしまったら
すべて茶色になって ひとつになってしまう
「いいじゃない？これで」って
ただこうなるとやはり
いち個人自身が 皆さん
「私はユニークだ 私の色を出したい」
ってすぐになるわけですね
ですので 完璧にそれは実現不可能でしょう
じゃぁそれぞれの色が混ざり合わずに
ひとつの要素として とりあえず共存しよう
「サラダボウル」と言われますけども
これもやはり混ざり合いが
もうちょっとあった方がいいんじゃないか？
最近では
「あなたの色はもう私には見えません」と
「もう私はカラーブラインド 色盲だ」
っていうアイデアもあります
もちろんこれは最初と同じで
非常に反発があるんですね
「いや 逆に私の色を見てくれ」と
しかしこういうことを繰り返していって
そして新しいグローバライゼーションが
進む世の中で
本当に新しいコンビネーションが
いろいろできています
これをどう考えるか？
人は見たことのない色を見ると
ひょっとしたら自分のものさしで
どうにかこれを理解しようとします
ここにやはり先入観であったり
ステレオタイプがあるかもしれません
そして この先入観はそれぞれの
ものさしによって作られてくるんですが
それによって標準というアイデアも出てきます
そもそも標準ってなんでしょうね？
各社会にあると思います
この国やこの空間には この色が似合っている
こういった人が似合ってる
じゃぁ例えば 私 先ほど
「須本」と紹介されました
下の名前はエドワードと言うんですけども
名前を言ってしまうと
いろいろなストーリーが
出てくるかもしれませんけども
ある時 私は家を借りるために
不動産に行ったんですね
不動産に行きまして 私
ある物件に興味があったんです
そしたら 不動産の方が大家さんに
「こちらに家を借りたい人がいるんですけど
彼 見た目が日本人なんで
たぶん大丈夫だと思います」
って言ってくれたんですね
で 「あぁ そやねー」っていう
「標準を満たしているからね」
っていう自分で思いはあったんですけども
そこからやっぱり
喜怒哀楽が全部きたんですね
なんで私はこれに対して
違和感を感じているんだろう？と
そこにやはり私は日本人としても
もちろんプライドもありますし 日本人だと
しかし そこの中に まぎれもなく
エドワードであったり ルーツであったり
親から受け継いだもの
こういった標準を満たさないものがあって
それもすべて私の一部
そして私がたぶん感じていたのは
それを無視されたり
もしくは
表現できていないんじゃないかという
そういう違和感ですよね
とすると よく考えてみると
これは私だけの問題ではなくて
世界中のいろんな多様な人
LGBTの人だったり 障がいを持っている人
移民であったり 難民であったり
社会のすぐ身の回りにいる
いろんな色の人は
それぞれ 表現したくても
表現しきれないものがあるんじゃないか？
ですので 私の活動でもこういった考え方でも
何を大事にしてるかというと
ただ単に発信するだけではなくて
どうお互いを見て
その間の色を見ていくか？
どういう意味を見い出すか？
これだけしゃべっていると
非常にわかりにくいので
じゃぁ これをワークショップであったり
そういうことに生かせる
なにか見方がないかと考えました
まず 視点の整理ですね
自分 もしくは当事者
この個人がいます
そして それに対してもちろん社会
これが一番わかりやすい
２つのセットです
しかし そこには個人が所属する
何かの背景があります
ですからこの上にコミュニティー
というものを付けています
この人は例えば障がい者
この人はハーフ
こういったコミュニティーだったり仲間
こういうくくりがあるかもしれません
理想的にはこの３つを
つなぎ合わせるということです
そして このように今交差している所に
いろいろ見ることができるんですけども
これだけでも
まだ少しわかりにくいです
せっかく色の話をしているので
色[を]ベースにこの視点を分けてみました
まず１つは当事者の視点
そして もう１つは社会の視点
みなさんこれをご存知かもしれませんけども
色の原色 そして光の原色に基づいて
ちょっとヒントを得ています
説明しますと
これが当事者の視点です
ちょっと覚えていらっしゃる方もいると
思いますけども
光の原則によると
すべての光の色が集まると真っ白になる
この真ん中の状態ですね
つまり個人だったり その当事者が
私の中のアイデンティティであるもの
すべて伝えたいもの
それが100%伝わっている状態だと
考えてみましょう
この場合 光を足していくと
この理想に繫がるわけなんですけども
いくら個人が努力しても 多分
ここに達成するのは非常に難しいと思います
そういう中で
何を自分は表現しようとしているのか
社会にはどういう風にそれが伝わっているのか
これが間の色だったりすると思うんですね
そして コミュニティと社会の間の
接点であったり
こういう風な形にリストしていくんですね
それぞれの自分だったり
当事者 社会が
どういう力があるのか どういう見方があるか
どう通じていないか
逆にヒントにしているのは
社会の目線の場合は色の原則です
こちらの矢印は
外に行っているんですけども
というのもペンキなど塗られると
色の原則の場合 全ての色を混ぜ合わすと
真っ黒になってしまいます
この色の原則の場合は 色を引くことよって
新しい色を作るという原則です
つまり最初の真ん中の真っ黒は
自分のものさしで塗り固められている真っ黒な
これ以上色が付けられない そして
本当の色もわからない状態かもしれません
こちらの場合でも エクササイズとして
どういった接点があるのか
間にどういう交差があるのか
そして社会はその当事者を見るとき
その所属するコミュニティーを見るときに
だんだん色 先入観 自分のものさしを
引いていくと
間の色が見えていくということです
論理上はこういうことですので
実際にこれが完璧に交差することはありません
そのためにもこの２つの違う色の原則は
使いやすいんですけども
現実はこのように最低限方向性が
同じ方向を向いて
そして なんとなく色が重ねあって
そしてさらに新しい色が生まれていく
こういう風な社会が
まさに多様性に いろんな色に
柔軟な社会なんじゃないかと思ってます
これを実際に使っています
例えば こういった色を使った
ワークショップなどいろいろあるんですけども
例えばセミナーでマジョリティと
マイノリティを入れ替えて議論する
これもそうなんですけども
アートだったり音楽を通して
こういった表現のワークショップ
相手の立場だったり アイデンティティを聞く
ワークショップ
こういうことをやるとさらにすんなりと
いろんな世代にも伝わりやすくなります
この場合は 2008年からやっていた
社会のいろいろな固定観念であったり
そういう ものさし 心 感情を 揺れ動かす
そして未来につなげていく
「シェイクフォワード」という
名前を付けたんですけども
こういった音楽イベントと
ワークショップをやってました
そこには実は当初６組のグループが出てまして
アイヌ、日系ブラジル
日系ペルー、ベトナム難民２世
アフロジャパニーズ、コリアン
非常にメッセージ性の多い
そういったさまざまな日本国内にいる
そういう多様なミュージシャンに
出てもらいました
そして音楽性だけでなく
こういったワークショップを開催し
関東と関西でやるんですけども
地域の青少年に
自分をまるで象徴するような色
もしくは好きな色
これを選んでもらいます
これに連動して
言葉やフレーズを選んでもらって
そして最終的には
アーティストと一緒にひとつの曲を作って
それを表現する
自分の色をどう相手に伝えるか
こういったことを
この場合はアートを使ってやってみました
少しご覧にいれます
（動画開始）
ナレーション：次の日は会場を鷹取教会に移して
昨日のアーティストたちと
ワークショップが開かれました
作った詩をみんなで発表します
男性：ひとりひとりの心の色という形で
心のオーロラというテーマで作りました
（歌声開始）
男性：セクシーで始めよう
女性その他：オッケー（拍手）イエーイ
女性：セクシー...
（歌声）
男性：セクシー マイカラー
その他：マイカラー（歓声）
（歌声）
ナレーション：自分たちで作った詩を
プロのアーティストが
歌ってくれたのを見て
感動で泣きそうになりました
男性歌：「人生は色々」
「透明の未来」
観客：（掛け声）
男性歌：光の時計
（歓声）（拍手）
矢野デイビッド：すごく内容が濃くて
なんかまた
新しいパワーを得れましたね
みんなやっぱり
幸せになりたかったりとか
より良い世界を
作ろうとしているんだなと
そのためにやっぱりみんながもっと
ひとつになったりとか
もっと自分の中に抱えているものを
もっと出さないと
なにが一番いいのかわからないんだな
というのが僕の個人的な意見です
聞き手：えっと...なに人ですか？
石川ホベルト：日系ブラジル人です
聞き手：[私]と同じですね（笑）
石川：同じかー（笑）
石川：ま 僕は日本人
ま 何ていうの？
日本人としてできることは
一杯あるんですけれども
逆にブラジル人の存在感
ブラジル人としての存在感とか経験を
何ていう？
日本人のためにいろいろ...見せたい
ま そういう
ブラジル人の面を出したいなっていう感じ
聞き手：はいはいはい
石川：逆にブラジル人に僕の中にある
日本人の部分を見せてあげたいね
っていう感じなんですね
聞き手：はい
石川：日本にいる日本人なのだけど
ブラジル人
（女性歌声始まり）
（歌）...心一つにして
歩いて行こう
ハッピーハッピーハッピー
...
（女性歌声終了）
（拍手）
ありがとうございます
まあ まさに
こんなにいろいろ話していますけれども
参加してくれた皆さんの色から
私が学んだことを
今日は皆さんに
お伝えしているだけなんですね
こういうわかりやすい例もありますけども
以前私はここ神戸で
95年に被災をしたんです
その後 国連で地域開発を通して
途上国で地域開発をしたり防災をする
そういう仕事につくこともできたんですけども
そういった際に学んだことは やはり
何か社会問題でも 何か問題があった時
その問題に巻き込まれている人たちが
問題の一部として見られる
これは未来に繫がらない
そうではなくて
彼ら自身に解決策があり
彼ら自身が何か
ユニークな力を持っている
例えばコミュニティの中の女性であったりとか
社会的弱者と言われる人たちでも
それなりの知識だったり
自分たちに適した何か解決法を知っている
そして自分たちのユニークな
パーソナリティ[や]カラーがある
この色の話に通ずるところは
まさにこういったいろいろな多様性
こういったものを柔軟に
未来に生かすこと
これこそが一緒に共に実施する
参加型のまちづくり
この神戸でもやってきたことだと思います
最後にですね みなさんに
元の絵に戻るんですけども
こちらの絵の元となった写真を
お見せしたいと思います
これが 実際の子どもたちなんですけども
今はもうちょっと大きくなっちゃって
何年か前ですので
みなさんはこの写真を見たときに
どういったストーリーを
思い浮かべるでしょうか？
実際にここに写っているのは
４組の兄弟と姉妹です
みなさん日本人なんですけども
日本プラス６か国のルーツを持っています
こんな多様でカラフルな世界が
もう既にみなさんの周りに存在するんですね
ぜひ皆さんもこういったいろいろな色
そして自分の色も表現しながら
すべての人とすべての色に力を
そして未来につなげることを
一緒にできればと思います
どうも今日はありがとうございました（拍手）